all right look adamandeve.com we love it
uh who wants better
sex and who wants to start having better
sex immediately duh that's everyone that
will be everyone I think probably the
best way to get started is to go to
adamandeve.com right now Adam and Eve is
offering 50 off just about any item plus
free shipping which includes Rush
processing you get it quickly more than
that
Adam and Eve wants to make your life
easy they offer discreet shipping as
your privacy is priority plus 100 free
shipping with Rush processing on your
entire order that means if you want to
get like a dildo or something like that
or whatever it is some uh uh uh jelly
you know what I mean all whatever it is
sex foam whatever you want you get it
it's discreet nobody knows what it is
yes dude it doesn't matter how much you
spend or what you buy it will be
packaged and sent discreetly for free
and fast uh 50 off one item free
shipping with free Rush processing uh so
go to adamandeve.com and select any one
item it could be an adventurous new toy
or anything you desire just enter offer
code Lifeline at checkout that's
Lifeline
l-i-f-e-l-i-n-e at adamandeve.com this
exclusive offer is specific to this
podcast so be sure to use this code
Lifeline to get your discount 100 free
shipping and get it fast with rust
processing code lifeline
are far or you know a fart even like the
smell of the house is it okay you know
to mention it's obviously a fart I don't
get ones like this what do you think
what do you mean ones like this you're
the one who let it through oh far well I
mean I want to let them through because
I want you guys to understand eviscerate
them really
wow playing God playing God
[Music]
wow
hello hello
[Music]
yeah no I don't want any of them
um loser dude
leg hurts today and you're and you're in
a bad mood because of it that's not why
I'm in a bad mood oh you're in a mad
tell everybody why you got in a bad mood
he got in a bad mood right before we
started recording and I could tell he
was about to [__] blow up and and I
take back that f word and you know what
I did instead I said guys I'm getting
frustrated can we just start the show
yeah but I could because maybe because
I'm your brother I knew already I know
but that's what's exploding but my point
is before that yes I have to look on you
I was like that's I know that look but
the reason yes of course you do but the
reason why I said I'm frustrated can we
start to show was to let people know I
get it storms are coming so you've been
therapized and you're doing better yeah
but I'm stressing the point that I
already knew anyway I know I understand
that but that's necessarily they don't
necessarily understand that which is why
I said what I said but what happened is
you started agreeing with me as if you
knew what my point was but you didn't
and then I had to go back and say no
that was my point and that kind of got
papered over so I want to say one more
time clean don't say it again without
being said but both times it got
compromised and stepped on I don't think
I think everyone honestly knows what
happened okay so so you don't have to
say it I don't have to say it again no I
think everyone's knows what happens and
I think that everyone also knows that I
know what you are saying okay and then I
said something different I just knew
because the way you look on their face
that's fine I already knew that okay
that was the third time but I'm done
okay but
I I figured you knew even because of
you're my brother they might not have
known that I figured that the audience
not them thought he didn't even see it
we didn't even have it on camera it was
beforehand no it wasn't we got that on
camera no no not the me being frustrated
part yeah right correct that's what I'm
saying yeah well I had to illustrate it
yeah I think you're just honestly dude
you're dead wrong right now I I don't
think you understand
uh you know what I'll say this is what I
was getting frustrated about is we're
launching a patreon yes you could sign
up right now dude patreon.com
Lifeline luxury that's what it's called
and um it's starting you know we're
starting when we want to start uh we
know we're halfway through the month but
we're you know full-fledged firing on
all s well let's say cylinders uh July
uh I'm sorry June June which is next I
didn't mean to say July I don't know
they shouldn't have two months with to
start with J back to back on four
letters
they're both ju I agree and if you agree
with that you said it so you can't agree
with the things what I'm saying about
how you said four letters nju and I
didn't say that so I'm giving you credit
oh okay so do you agree that it's they
shouldn't have that
July should be somewhere before December
it just
uh I'm kind of down with like the cute
like light I guess JJ the summer Vibe
like it gets you into the summer Vibe
with like the two kids I gotcha okay
well they got me okay yeah whoever made
that I've been gotten Mr months by the
Gregorian calendar mix okay yep so uh
they got you and um we are starting uh
thing on patreon where we're going to do
uh at least two episodes a month
um uh they're called Lifeline luxury and
they're half hour episodes uh or so you
know there'll be maybe some some longer
some well no they won't be shorter but
um and uh it's just gonna be Matt and I
uh no no callings no nothing just being
just just bantering right stories are
personally yeah they're not stories got
some future stories that haven't
happened yet that we'll be able to a lot
of people like what we do the first 10
minutes of the show which is just us
kind of you know sometimes it's five
minutes sometimes it's ten minutes we're
gonna do full uh at least half hour
patreon two at least two times a month
and it's called lifeline so patreon.com
Lifeline luxury sign up definitely sign
up by June but it's live now if you want
to do it uh if you want to sign up
um so anyway that's what's up so yay
congratulations yay uh my tour is at
chrisley.com will be in Nashville I'll
be in Pittsburgh I'll be in all sorts of
different places uh Pueblo Colorado uh
boys Boise and um Utah soon uh but
anyway go to get tickets chrisley.com
Philadelphia let's do it and uh and you
know if you want solo sessions with your
boy
bad about it for Zoom sessions I was
gonna say phone but it's actually Zoom
sessions you can look at my face I can
look at your face and we can get down to
the nitty-gritty one-on-one at
mantelia.com book your session now uh
and then you can leave us a message on
the hotline
213-973-8095 or you have a question
click the link below or go to watch
lifeline.com I wonder why that TV is I
also wonder this I gotta keep doing this
right and that's something that
absolutely should have been
if we're just gonna be lay it down be
completely honest
I
just hit this totally uh the way he's
dealing totally agree yeah but it's not
and that's fine but that's what's up so
uh too many letters too many letters
yeah well see those aren't that's not
nope he's doing it so uh it's fine so
anyway uh let's get back to the actually
the what we were talking about is not
the patreon but my leg hurts but also
the merch get your life get your merch
at lifelinemirch.com yeah it's very good
merch so uh and by the way I see people
on the road I was in um where was I
Cincinnati and uh Columbus they have the
lifeline merch too and they like you
they're like oh nice you know what
someone came up to me and stuck your
face someone came up to me at Whole
Foods the other day and said Hoover Rich
place and said are you Matt Dalia and I
said yeah I mean I'm it's possible to
recognize me from a lot of different
things because I've been a lot of
different things okay critically
acclaimed stuff sort of stuff sort of
stuff like like this for the people monk
don't forget monk okay
um and uh I said yes and he said
it's cool to see you standing up
so it's obviously from the podcast uh I
know but it took like did you play a
paraplegic in Franklin and back I needed
to yeah it was so believable yeah he
thought I was really in a wheelchair no
dude
that is such a weird thing to say first
it's kind of a cool thing to say are you
matalia yes huh cool I've never seen you
standing up that wait hold on that's
what happened that's different then it's
cool to see you standing up what did he
say I've never seen you standing up and
it's cool to see you standing up you're
two different things and I think one of
them I've never seen you standing up
yeah that is not a cool thing to say
that's a weird thing to say yeah it's
cool to see you standing up now that's a
cool thing to say and that's a sexy guys
say stuff like that like me really
thinking about it on the sexy scale I'm
just thinking about the weird scale
never seen you standing up before it's
like I felt very studied I felt like I
felt on like under a microscope I don't
remember walking around that's why I
said keep walking you said keep I said
keep walking no you did yeah I said yeah
keep walking those are the only teams
that's so rude
no no no it went like this hey are you
mad to Leah yeah
I've never seen you standing up before
keep walking that's how it's so rude the
rudest guy of all time yeah uh you know
so I will say uh uh we're glossing over
the fact that my leg hurts and that's
not cool you keep I don't know your leg
hurting I want to know why is that
interesting to talk about so here's the
only thing that I've done differently in
my life
and this would make a lot of sense but
then I have a caveat of when my leg
hurts this could make a lot of sense
you're leaving
that's slowly trying to get away with
leaving yeah so this is this would make
a lot of sense but I want you to wait
for the caveat okay because you remind
you okay
because if I just say the thing and be
like well that's obviously what it is I
get it but I have a caveat I know you
have learned the word caveat today
so I did lime scooters for hours I did
lime scooters I did lime scooters two
hours two days in a row for hours
now doesn't that sound like that would
make what my leg hurt right oh I see
yeah sure right yeah here's the caveat
yeah okay so you said you wouldn't do
that so it's a caveat you asked I know
but I'm saying if I didn't know is that
a test no no it wasn't a test I get it
okay that's on me but here's the caveat
that was
Saturday and Sunday it's gonna make you
mad at what I say and it is Wednesday
it's gonna make you mad what I said I
don't know what you're gonna say and I'm
pissed it and I'm I'm pissed I know
preemptively so tell them what I'm gonna
say he's gonna say yeah sometimes it
takes a while for things to start
happening and it's probably the sort of
thing yeah I'm pissed
it's actually a especially true when
they're muscles that you really not ones
that have atrophy but have are like less
commonly used by you right you don't use
your leg muscles you don't walk anywhere
you don't get on a bike ever you don't
you don't do you don't run
dude I'm I'm slacked you what I I do
jumps I'm great what is a jump what a
jump is jumping I jump what are you six
years old no I'm just saying I I work
out sometimes in during the workout you
jump yeah to wear like how what you're
working out you're like okay now now I'm
doing jumps jumps is a good workout dude
I jump I believe you but I don't believe
that you do him
everything's so light everything's so
light
so strong bouncing all over
um so so yeah so anyway so that's what's
up and that's fine but I bet I was there
yeah right when you were screaming first
an eyewitness an eyewitness I bet you
you hurt yourself when you almost fell
off the scooter okay well so oh now
we're airing it now the truth comes out
we have a witness and you got screwed
over for that let's just I didn't fall
off the scooter okay it sounds like you
all David first of all David fell off
the scooter and rolled and tumbled on
the grass and we went like like doing
that it was so funny we have it on video
how did you not dude I'm so
pissed at you what you're saying how
could you not tell me that I'm telling
you right now but how could you wait
this long to tell me it's like your leg
it's like it takes four days for your
leg to start hurting how could you wait
four days to tell me that you have on
video our friend David Sullivan who has
the largest skull bone yeah in the world
did the earth crack when his head hit
the ground no but I will tell you what
wow it's gonna it's it's well I didn't
get it with my phone we got it with the
actual camera so it's gonna be on the
Vlog so I'll send you the Vlog when it
comes out it'll be the Cincinnati
Columbus Vlog whatever it was but oh wow
but dude it is the tour report but dude
he fell and and I mean oh my God it was
so [__] funny
oh he got it wow and I watched it happen
it was right next to me he rolled past
he's 46 dude he's 40. what did he say
the first thing after he got up man
but when he was on the ground was he's
like oh he was a defensive he was
smiling no he was like okay good he knew
it I know I know I wish it was damn I
know I wish it like hurt a little too
much but he he was rolling and couldn't
stop and and was smiling as he was about
to fall because he knew he was [__]
that's great it was so good that's great
but that I still wish he was nervous
or like wanted to make it seem like it
was gonna happen or it doesn't hurt yeah
yeah yeah yeah perfect that's always the
best but no it was great it was still
funniest it's still a high hilarity but
so it'll be on the Vlog but so make sure
you sign up to my crystalia channel but
um yeah yeah yeah but uh so anyway so
that's what happened so I think that
that might be what my leg is but if not
it might be uh you know who knows maybe
it's a [__] huge why would your leg
hurt because David Sullivan fell what do
you guys so twins I wanted him to know
that the reason why I fell is because of
um no the reason why I have is David
Fell I did not fall I know that I get it
it almost fell and what you did I
wouldn't say I almost fell but did you
almost fall because David almost hit me
over no no no it was separate it's
everything so why are you denying it
because I want people to know that 10
miles an hour what you had to do to stop
yourself from falling is you probably
twist your knee or something like that
yeah how could you leave that out me
yeah I don't even remember that
happening but not leaving it out you're
doing another one talking think about
how it happened and now I remember it
happened okay wow blocked it out blacked
it out but I don't know if that's what
it was couldn't bear to think about it
anyway there are four days ago that that
happened and now my leg Yeah Dude yes
because you don't use your legs a lot
that's why I do use my legs a lot I do
jumps okay but anyway dude I'm fit but
we should go sign up for Lifeline luxury
patreon.com Lifeline luxury
um and uh and we're gonna do episodes
just where we just do that and not take
people's videos insufficient so uh
because a lot of people like that part
of the show exclusively so that's what
we're gonna do well we asked what would
you want to hear if you had another yep
a lot of people yeah people said exactly
what we're gonna do so you're welcome
yeah put your money where your mouth is
and keep it moving right isn't that what
you said to the guy keep it moving keep
walking yeah yeah yeah yeah all right so
uh let's go let's go let's take some
first submissions let's do it
hello big fan robot Chris I saw you in
Oakland a few years back Matt delete is
confused as one of the best podcasts of
all time thank you thank you here's the
Dilemma my friend who is very lonely one
on Facebook a while back and was looking
through his friend's friends list and
finding women that he could hit up for
nudes not the way I would go about it
but to each their own I guess okay just
ended up sending news to this person who
he thought was perfectly legitimate and
after exchanging the nudes they sent him
a message asking him for 500 or they
would share these nudes with everybody
on his friends list
after paying this person a few weeks
passed and they came back asking for
another 500 I don't say this cycle
repeated until he paid them I think
twenty five hundred dollars and then
they stopped reaching out to him they
did a year or so has passed now
and they are reaching out again for more
money what should my friend do should he
continue to pay this person who is
threatening him or should he just say
[__] it
let's moment of silence for this
absolute [__] before we dive in here I
mean how dumb why do you want to send
over some nudes without even like like
you don't go online in General Financial
Bill and try to find like people to send
people to exchange people have different
Kinks though I guess yeah I mean I guess
I mean I definitely know women have told
me like men send unsolicited
which blows my mind yeah who ever got a
dick pic and was like huh I think I like
this guy that never happened I've never
in my life sent a dick pic yeah that's
yeah yeah so I just I don't I don't
trust that [__] so you're the opposite
of this guy you haven't ever seen one
even two people I know right okay so so
here's the thing the guy maybe to like
friends I have like to you okay are like
okay well that's yeah but not not zero
women that you know deserves an
explanation but I'm gonna pretend but uh
one time I put a cloth over it and I
said oh no there's a ghost in my house
and I sent it to Brian Callum okay well
I believe that
um scary
so um but but but I have a friend that
this has happened to I do too yeah it's
common yeah so your friends even dumber
for that reason if it's a thing that
people know about it's a scam it's like
that Nigerian gold scammer or whatever I
think it's not as known as the Nigerian
thing maybe not but but that's just like
the Nigerian thing still works I guess
this still happens yeah and I think
you know obviously he made a mistake by
paying anything to begin with
your toast it happened it's coming out
yeah the end that's your it has to be
your mentality right yeah it happened
the the photos are gonna come out and
that's that I guess but but it's
possible that that they would never do
anything if you just ignored them that
is it's possible they would never leak
anything because
like they're not getting money it's just
it's more worshipful thing is it's gonna
come out
if it's going to come out the money has
nothing to do with it yeah basically I
mean the but I'm saying that's the way
you need to think so let's erase the 25
2500 you already did it it's already in
the hole it's already gone bye bye now
we're gonna see it again bye bye don't
need to do all that but yeah uh I don't
really don't like the last bye bye bye
bye 2500 that's gone forever yeah that
sucks it's a goodbye thank you for
coming loved having you Jada sorry to
see you go but you're gone all good okay
um so
now you're back at zero and you're gonna
say
no money for you yeah I'm done if you
need to do it do it if you you know
whatever but don't message me anymore
I'm gonna give you no more money if you
have to blast my photo to everybody I
know so be it no I don't even think you
should say then okay they're not gonna
do it well they might not
but this is what you do to ensure that
they don't oh okay the way you say that
yeah is like this
send it to everyone
right and then don't say anything else
go ahead send it to everyone bye don't
don't hit me up anymore
I think that's the way to really make
sure probably right yeah because you
seem like yeah you legitimately don't
care but they already know he cares
because he paid 2500 right but people
grow people change and maybe now he
doesn't care so forget also here's the
other thing dude this guy has maybe tell
this guy this
uh you don't who cares who cares it's I
get there's the shame involved or I sent
the nude but honestly
I've never sent a nude that's
that's an anomaly it's very rare that
nobody it's very rare that you find
somebody that's never sent a nude right
yeah sure yeah who cares they all know
they've secretly done it so who cares
I don't I don't get I mean unless you've
got like some seriously some small penis
or some [__] which I don't if this if
this somehow happened to me I need a
wide lens and somebody was like I want
to show everybody yeah if you don't pay
me 500 I would just be like can't wait
huh yep look can't wait all right all
right can't wait you're not gonna get my
money yeah I know I'll do it you know
what I mean I'll do it uh actually you
know what no stop it stop right there
let me do it yeah then I would blast the
exact same photo of me to all everyone
in my friend group take pictures of a
screenshots as proof send it back to
that guy just to show them how much I
don't care at all right right yeah yeah
but we're also very different in that
hole who cares confidence thing
you know I don't I don't know if it's
I'm not taking it from a confidence
standpoint though it's actually just
like a common sense standpoint they're
never going to stop asking for money so
do you have any money no right yeah so
you only have one alternative is to kiss
them goodbye and say yeah but don't do
it off with you yeah okay off with you
right but I I think that
um it's just I had a buddy that that
just happened to and he said oh no I
guess just send it to everyone because
I'm not going to pay you and and he said
that and the person never did it yeah
yeah okay thank you yeah I didn't see I
didn't even know that but yeah
um it was an idiot he's an idiot for
doing it
that which party is needed for for
sending a picture to somebody that he
didn't well I don't
he so didn't know that unless it's your
girlfriend or or something or boyfriend
well obviously okay obviously that's
okay but if it's somebody any less than
that don't ever do it and also don't do
it if it's your girlfriend or boyfriend
because they're they lie first of all do
it if you want if it's someone you think
you trust like whatever life is short
yeah and and who cares if something goes
sideways and like but just like don't
look for people you've never met to
exchange news with yeah that is stupid
exactly but that's somebody but that's
his Kink probably so it's like oh I mean
that's a strange King yeah well they're
strange ones anyway your friend is an
idiot and already messed up but moving
forward he doesn't have to keep being an
idiot he can stop being an idiot and
from now on be less of an idiot right
all right so give them that advice from
from us to him Sealed With a Kiss okay
yeah okay cool all right next one
foreign
Jiu Jitsu back in the day which is crazy
to me because I couldn't imagine you
rolling around with a bunch of sweaty
dudes well what I like that but uh I
trained Jiu Jitsu full time and I'm
injured right now and I just want to
know how you guys deal with like when
you can't do your passion or your job
due to an injury or like life
circumstances like when something is so
pivotal to your life uh that's like an
anchor that you do every day when you
stop doing it it like you kind of feel
like well what am I doing with my time
so I'm just kind of curious what you
guys would do any advice would help love
you guys Chris I saw you in Austin and
it was amazing thanks bro keep killing
it and thanks thanks bro I'm just like I
look like he does Jiu Jitsu yeah he does
look what I mean yeah he I bet he's good
at it too um well if it's just full-time
yeah uh it's uh yeah well when I did
that was actually I was thinking about
this the other day I always think about
the other day how weird it is I agree
it's weird that you like that no it's
not
it is from the outside obviously it's up
to you no but it's not because you know
it to be but if you know the deep side
of me and I'll tell you why well maybe
you need to be more open about your deep
side because nobody you're you're an
enigma and a mystery I like no
one-on-one stuff what does that mean
like I I don't like sports people
usually think like oh oh oh people
that's not the reason why okay yeah and
I think same with him it's the closeness
of physical contact I like the mixing
stuff bodily fluids and weirdness yeah a
lot of potential weirdness you know
um
well yeah but also [__] man there's some
weirdos there uh so and I love weirdos
but yeah I was just thinking about this
the other day how much it sucks
for people who do like Combat Sports or
or martial arts how much time like when
you're injured you don't get to do it
that sucks dude it's happening it
happened back in the day didn't it like
you got well so you know they say if
you're not hurt you're not training
right but uh yeah my knee yeah I got
knee surgery but then uh
you know I don't know you have to figure
out I don't know what your injury is but
it's like it obviously it's all part of
it so you know they say that a lot of
the advancement in even physical stuff
has to do with you thinking about it
while you're not doing it uh which I
always thought was interesting but um
yeah yeah I you know it's just
interesting yeah like take the time that
you would have been training to think
about right previous training sessions
what could have happened differently how
you could do certain things at certain
times that's that's actually a good
point yeah yeah so there's that it's not
it's fun obviously but um it also isn't
gonna have the same effect on your brain
like you just like you're not no you're
sitting there not moving but but if
you're worried about productivity versus
none like that that is something yeah
but it also helps in a different way I
think yeah you know so
um you could be thinking more critical
about it rather than just reacting in
the moment but
um
yeah I don't know I mean my passion is
you know stand up but uh I I took a
break from it for a few months but uh
you know I
I don't know it's uh it was okay it was
okay a year actually I said I don't know
how long yeah I didn't do it for a year
but um
I mean I was dealing with other [__] but
like you have to like
you have to just learn how to be okay
with it maybe that's part of it dude I
mean especially with martial arts they
say like a lot of it is in your mind and
a lot of it has to do with you know so
maybe just the waiting part will help
yeah I think you I think you actually
do like do yourself some kind of favor
and not think about how much it sucks
that you can't do that other thing and
know that you assuming it's a long-term
injury and it's going to take some time
to come back from it you're gonna have
to find something else that at least
sort of somewhat fulfills you and I
would just say be open to what that
might be instead of sitting around being
upset that you can't go train anymore
think of it in this way I I'm gonna just
be the reality is I'm going to be out
for x amount of months or weeks whatever
I need to find something else and then
find it some of the most interesting
things that I either think about or read
about or look have read like looking
looked into uh have I've stumbled upon
because I was like what I think a lot of
people call being bored but that's why
that stuff isn't boring like at any
second you can stumble into something
that you're really interested in yeah
that's how I got into cobbling so give
give yourself a chance I would say like
uh to find something new yeah you know
what's cobbling cobbling is making shoes
uh oops I knew it I know I didn't knew
it while you were saying it but I was
insecure about knowing it because I
thought maybe it was wrong but we said
making I go shoes with you I didn't like
it what you did though it does but but
that's necessary for me so let's go to
the next one
stop always thinking I'm looking at you
I'm looking hey man hey Chris um my name
is Dede
um I guess my question is uh late at
night my roommates will get up and turn
the AC on Oh They'll blast it I get it
it'll be like um you know maybe 54
degrees outside which is pretty cold
where I am and um they'll they'll um
they'll they'll make it like 65. and
then sometimes 69 as well
um which is not you know
no you don't do that I know that that's
wrong I guess my question is what do I
uh what do I say to them you know I want
to be a mean guy I appreciate them I
think they're nice people I just I don't
really know how to how to go about that
because it's uh you know it's cold
all right thank you I mean how much is
okay sounds like your radio I mean he's
also an actor in in movies with Molly
Ringwald yeah well he just he's got such
a good voice I mean that guy should 100
be on the radio yeah have his own
podcast you gotta you gotta my advice to
you is start a podcast no look that's
horrible did you say that this call is
for me because you know I hate that [__]
Marco yeah uh
you wake up and put the [__] heat on
that's [__] up dude 64 degrees then
you gotta be hot and uncomfortable like
oh I love that it's not but okay but
that's not what never put the air on if
if it's 54 degrees outside you there's
no reason to ever ever ever ever yeah
ever just tell your guys say why don't
you open a window yeah this is [__]
I wake up freezing I'm gonna get sick
yeah it's also very very possible this
is true of most dwellings you could very
easily be in the room that has the worst
circulation for the air and it just
comes out and ices everybody no matter
where you are in it or what time of day
whatever what it's like outside they
could be in a room that has like worse
like a less effective cooling off of the
room you need to let them know yeah that
your room gets freezing and also
it's already cold outside why can't you
just open a window if he hasn't let them
known know at all yeah that's and that's
what you say you say yo what's up with
the room I feel like because this is my
room is really cold when you put the air
down so maybe you could just open up a
window that's the move but if you've
brought it up a bunch of times and they
haven't said anything I don't think he's
brought it up there yeah I don't think
so either but if you haven't then you
got it then it's worth all that Warfare
sure break the thermostat yup break the
thermostat break their legs yep dump ice
in their bed when they're sleeping
yeah you know in their moms in their
shoes before yep icing their shoes yep
steal money from them steal money from
them
yeah okay stuff like that so we figured
it out yeah I don't know man do you like
what do you like your temperature at
right okay so what do you put your
thermostat at because you have to put it
either 70 yeah put that 70. but then
it'll dip and then when it does it comes
back up to 70 or back down to 70. so 70
as well so it's hot out I put the AC on
70. okay so what I like it's cold I put
the heat yeah okay so that's very uh how
do I say it
a rudimentary irregular yeah that's very
rudimentary but it's rudimentary it's
crude it's simple that's what you do
yeah it is simple right but I do why
would I complicate because because
things are a little different things are
the bodies aren't so aren't so simple
are they well from body to body I guess
not right so even even honestly one body
take one body that's not so simple
I don't think that's your point though
so yeah that's true but my point is that
you need to have some sort of finesse
with it
when it comes to the air dude I totally
agree okay you gotta have the right
touch my house happens to be like that
got it got it okay it took me a while to
realize to realize that your house is
finesse was just kind of kind of
rudimentary it also depends on what room
I'm in if I'm in my bedroom
okay other rooms it's different okay
um I have
um I like so here's here's my thing I
like the temperature
4. that's what I like that's the
temperature so you never want the AC on
because rooms are rarely that hot so I
put the heat on 76 or 77.
what a maniac because it doesn't go up
there it doesn't know because that would
be rudimentary if I thought that I
should put it on 74. but then it's it
also goes up to 77 and as it never turns
on as it gets to 77 it cuts it goes back
down to 74. it never gets below 74. oh
see that's not my I know my move that's
the Finesse don't let it be above or
below depending upon if it's too cold or
too hot
can't you need the very minimum to be
yes what you like right but then don't
you like 77 no it's a little hot
so why are you setting it because if I
set it at 74 it'll dip down to 72. no it
won't yes it will the second it goes
below 74. if it runs in the different
houses are different well that's because
you got to make sure the thermostat's in
the right place right but but you don't
do that you just get in-house I did it
when I got my house I did it I said the
thermostat goes there but that doesn't
mean that that's where the vents go the
events go where the vents are already
you bought the house no no I had to put
in AC
seriously yeah yeah yeah yeah for real
okay so that's why it's built in like
1908 wow nobody ever thought to put AC
in back then they were just first summer
I lived there it was
filtering most miserable thing really
yeah and then wow dude it's it's uh
peace on Earth since then all right no
one yeah I think another one yeah
hey Matt hey Chris
um sorry I'm driving from work but I
just can't stop thinking about this
question that I have to ask you guys
really need your advices uh I'm an ER
nurse I'm literally leaving work right
now whoa and I'm trying to get out of
Virginia Beach
um I've been here for three years and I
don't think I would need to be nice
anymore
um so I applied overseas got a job in
England whoa Cambridge it's a three-year
contract
um the only downfall is this the pay is
like [__] uh to the point where I'm
afraid that I won't be comfortable nor
be able to travel like I would plan to
if I went there so I also applied back
home to San Diego and got the job offer
that also includes a hundred thousand
dollar sign-on bonus which is pretty
much unheard of for a nurse so my
question is if I should be practical or
not do I go back home where my family is
get that money and actually have money
to travel with or do I go have an
experience in England and just say [__]
it no anyways help me I'll definitely go
to San Diego
oh really bro well I'm trying to take
into account what she thinks is what
would be best for her not what would be
best for me I would obviously go to San
Diego but she is someone who wants to
travel wants to try new things she could
travel with that money
I guess yes she could but she could also
be
in a new place yeah she has to exciting
yeah yeah but I mean I don't know
something sounds fishy about that
England [__] like uh like a horror movie
no no like
you have this romantic idea of what it's
going to be like and it's just not going
to be of course it's not going to be
that right no that's true no matter what
it's worth pointing out yeah yeah uh you
know what San Diego is like you're from
there it's because the weather's also I
mean San Diego's weather is absolutely
unbelievable the greatest so I say go
back there make that money yeah look if
you're going to make more money yeah so
much also a lot more money right so much
to the point that you'll be able to
travel and wait I mean that seems like a
no-brainer yeah I get why you are
hesitant to do that but let me tell you
something about like being back where
you're from it's not as bad as like
movies and TV shows I totally agree bro
it's just a place you know really well I
totally agree unless something truly
traumatic happens to you somewhere right
it's just a place oh yeah I do that's
like every other place that's such a
great point so yeah also also you it's
not like you're not in you're it's not
like you're going to Fargo you're going
to San Diego which is a place you know
it's beautiful weather it's near La it's
near you know it's near a lot of other
places is like it's also where you're
going isn't like Paris or or Berlin it's
like a place in England she didn't even
say London true so it could just be
anywhere yeah and and places in England
are anybody ever been depressed okay
imagine exactly being 10 times that yep
and every time you open your eyes and
having to go like this a lot what and
then you see their teeth and they're all
[__] up well that's for sure but yeah
yeah England it has its great things
like London yeah and that's it and I
love it I'm not bad-mouthing England
like I love it I don't know who I am oh
okay I am really yeah but you've been
English but it doesn't matter the point
is
she might want to go to England that's
cool but like this could be in a this
could be like Slough you know I mean
like if you don't know where you're
going to be you've been in England
you've been in London where else oh
that's it I haven't been like around it
okay cool yeah I'm too scared most
people are the Google image scariest uh
generally the worst people on Earth wow
why do you say that I think they're
naughty naughty bad bad inside
something about growing up there you
just you're naughty naughty bad bad but
it's an adult by the time you're an
adult children I feel bad for them but
it's something the vibe of that place
whoa scary stuff so deep creates
monsters England creates monsters next
video okay
that'd be a good uh title for the
episode
hey man Chris 12.
I know I have a scab on my channel I've
seen the other guy but uh my question is
point that out my name's Aaron spelled
a-a-r-o-n yep okay and I knew that
because it was 47 times a day what's up
what blood boiling why every time blood
boils yeah so what's what's a good clap
back or a good spin move to when someone
calls me a Ron say hey [__]
so yeah I just okay I'm a small car and
I want to stop I really need some help
yeah have a have a Litany of them ready
to go though like yeah yeah the
dickhead's a small [__] yeah yeah tubbo
yeah yeah sure you know what I think
about all the time and I hate to do this
because it's sort of like
it's like bigging you up but thank you
ever so be it when you remember uh Kian
everybody listen yeah okay one time he
said wait what is it the one time he
said you're like friends with them so
you guys oh yeah yeah yeah yeah one time
he like went over the line and he was
like you got a big ass nose oh yeah and
then you were like you said something
like and I'm paraphrasing so maybe
correct me yeah at least I don't have a
big ass yeah right yeah yeah that was
good because he was kind of fat he was
fat so it was good smashed him smashed
him so jealous
Kian was great man he's a cool dude I
love it yeah
but yeah the only people that he ever
hung out with in high school was they
had funky last name yeah or first names
or parents that didn't speak English
you know my mom might have been funky
last names because like they had
immigrant names like even the yeah right
the the more American signing things
which always that's what I'm saying or
because Mom would be like you know it's
really great you're making friends here
in La when we moved to from um
Southern California from New Jersey but
I can't be friends with their parents
because they don't speak English yeah
that was a real thing I'd be like Marcus
you're gonna have to pick up a [__]
language huh yeah I gotta look up some
Japanese
is a really good friend you gotta learn
polish for Idis Mattis yep you know was
it polish I thought it was Russian no he
was polish all right and his sister was
in my grade right
exactly alike in fact she was so
beautiful but it was upsetting to look
at her because she looked so much like
itis oh really so much like artists
wow man all right well that's what it is
man uh hi itis I'm Morgan
because I didn't because I didn't want
people to think I think the key and had
a big ass
was a very good friend that's why I'm
saying good things but that was also
When We Were Young he might be you know
what it wouldn't surprise me if Keane
was very handsome I was surprised by fat
so uh all right
threw him a Lifeline then took it right
back
love you guys so much like such a nice
person
a boyfriend and we were having a house
party last Saturday and so we got the
house ready I helped him clean I bought
us a lot of alcohol and made some jungle
juice and jumbo juice I made it sounded
like such a big deal that I was there
and like meeting all of his friends and
he knows I have social anxiety so I told
him these things and I hate parties and
so I told him these things that would
help me and it made me feel more
comfortable and just not freak out and
the first person that got there
he didn't introduce me to them or to
anybody what and then from that point on
once that first person got there he
wouldn't stand by me or look at me or
talk to me include me in his
conversations or anything like at one
point we're literally in the kitchen and
he got everyone a shot except for me
like and I was standing right there and
it was like what where the [__] am I
here like
um but yeah so that was pretty shitty
and we were supposed to be moving in
together like my lease is up super soon
and I thought we were super great and
solid and apparently we're not so
any advice and I get that it's his house
and he had to entertain people but like
I was his girlfriend too yeah and that's
a bit extra this is super weird so any
advice on that would be great okay so
here's one thing just to consider first
off maybe he forgot forgot what that she
was his girlfriend just just during the
party no no no you don't think that was
it I think it's really weird and it's
hard to argue that that wasn't
intentional if it was it probably I want
to say it wasn't you're just yeah you're
inclined to but I if that is just
if she's just spitting facts right
that's impossible to believe there
wasn't some kind of intentionality to
what he was if if exactly what she is
saying is true which is obviously
there's it's always somewhere in the
middle so we would like to hear what the
guy said but it's I doubt your mission
she doesn't sound still angry about it
though sorry for my sense is she's
telling the truth or at least it's
understandable that that would be her
version of it does that make sense yeah
yeah I'd like to know that like what
she must have brought it up right that's
I mean I want to know imagine if you
didn't bring it up to him I want to know
what his reaction is like when you bring
it up and if you did bring it up to him
what was his reaction like because
that's
um really weird and I feel like
yeah
in did they break the most generous note
because she said I had a boyfriend and
that's how she started it I had this
boyfriend at the end she implied that
their lease is coming up she thought
everything was good but now she's not
sure that's the vibe I got okay that's
what I understood rather uh
before she totally finished my initial
thought was
he probably is because I you know I know
people
who
have never experienced a single moment
of anxiety
and I mean that's a lot of people yeah I
know people yeah and they they cannot
they cannot not that they will not not
that they don't want to not that they
want to disrespect it and poo poo on it
but they cannot understand what it is
yeah you cannot explain it Define it
it's not possible yeah it's not an
experience they can have so they need to
listen to you and sometimes that just
it's not that they're trying to be rude
or dismissive or even not pay attention
to your needs they it just for a lot of
people it can't register doesn't make
sense and it's not that they're not
trying it just like bounces right off of
them as for the social thing being said
yeah it's still dick
should at least that should make him go
the other way yeah
okay like am I being like am I
introducing enough people like are you
happy everything okay you know the fact
that he got everyone a shot except you
again it should be the opposite you
should come over I heard you do you
think can I help you like I know you
start you ten shots and then
filled you up wow and then and then put
her to sleep put her in a room so you
don't have to do it her anxiety wouldn't
have been you know yeah I just think you
know you are right to be deeply
perplexed I just think go go into
confronting him about it which you have
to go into confronting him about it not
with anger but with like with that yeah
confusion yeah don't don't be as you are
and deserve to be upset try to show the
side that is more just plainly confused
like I told you we talked about it what
happened like what happened yeah you
know definitely do that and let him
respond and depending upon how he
responds that's gonna dictate how either
angry or you know understanding you are
moving forward
why do you have a blue Chip's hat
because I saw it and liked it and I
loved the movie you know I think about
this movie all the time why because you
have the Hat no because I remember
distinctly thinking I was so excited to
see it and I was begging dad to take me
and he took me on opening night to see
Blue Chips starring Nick Nolte Shaquille
O'Neal and Fernie Hardaway it's
Christian JT Walsh
uh no that guy looks like Christian
laner but no he's just an actor he sucks
yeah he sucks what he sucks at acting
yeah yeah he's terrible he was just like
an actual basketball player oh it's like
an amateur somewhere yeah okay yeah uh
there were three main basketball players
in the late nurse a cool last name on
later yeah well he kind of cut me off
and okay you asked me a question and
then okay I was kind of answering it and
then you just slammed me it was
yesterday
yeah no Blue Chips is a great movie I
think about a lot it's it's personally
meaningful to me because of the opening
day Dad thing yeah it's like it's of a
really strong memory of the whole thing
and when I saw the Hat I was like that's
perfect for me oh cool you know what I'm
saying yeah I wasn't like looking for a
blue chip son you know right right I
took it I took Calvin to uh see Mario
the other day I didn't even know there's
a new married movie until you told me
that well you live under a rock it made
him nope it made a billion dollars so I
I know that now okay because I did my
work after I learned about it yeah and
then I took him today to get his haircut
and it was so cute man
and those two stories related well my
yeah my point is those core memories
those memories oh oh yeah you never know
when they're gonna pop up but I think as
a dad you want to try to have as many of
them as you can
man it was so funny we're playing we
were watching Mario and and he was like
just watching it and then an hour and he
says is it over yet oh wow that is funny
dude and I was like no do you want to go
home and he said yeah let's go home can
I bring my Sprite wow what happened
nothing
that he's just three he's done doesn't
do movies well no he he I mean it was
like an hour into it and he sat through
a whole movie before in the theater yes
but yeah but and then uh we we left and
I was like what'd you think about that
movie he said it was good but it was a
little bit scary yeah yeah and then I
said well who's your favorite character
he said Bowser and I said why is it
because he's scary I said so you like
Bowser and he was like yeah and I was
like I don't understand whoa you're so
conflicted already you know they're
gonna be such a deep adult you know I
know she's like Carl Young has a
three-year-old
I like it but I like it for a bunch of
different reasons and not just because
it makes me feel good I like to explore
the shadow in the Mario movie yeah
shadow of self yeah
okay so what he said after that go ahead
all right next one
my husband's a big fan of the podcast so
shout out to him if we can love him my
name is Tabby I'm from Iowa and our
debate lately has been homeschool versus
Public School uh private school if you
want to throw that in there too uh but
we're leaning more towards homeschool or
public school just because we had our
first kid it's going to be a little
while
um but she was due the same day that
Chris became a double dad so congrats oh
cool
um yeah what are your opinions
homeschool versus public school and um
if you guys want to ever come out to
Iowa that would be pretty cool uh have a
good one thanks I'll just teach I'll
just teach your kid um perfect for me I
I think homeschool is I I know times are
changing I you know I think more people
are doing homeschool now but like
I just feel like you get so much with
other kids you do but I think if it's
homeschool you got to make sure there's
tons of other planned social activities
whether that be you know sports or yeah
what are the I mean I don't even know
Boy Scouts Girl Scouts yeah but things
like that where they are still thrust
into situations not by choice that they
have to socialize and you know work with
compromise and all those things learn
those skills uh sharing all that stuff
but I will say you said times are
different now I dude I would be really
really selective and careful about the
public school I sent my kid to because
things are so crazy right now uh
and if if really if the public school
wasn't the real deal wasn't good right
and that might in my bones I knew that I
would figure out some way to homeschool
what about private school
I mean if you can afford it right yeah
it's very expensive but like who the
hell can afford price right right well
she did say throw that in there I know
but I assume yeah it's expensive be a
bank breaker even if you can't afford it
you so you would you would do that
homeschooling I would 100 do that but
here's the thing I'm really smart I
could handle that you wouldn't be able
to do that what
meaning you could either be the teacher
no I could oversee it I'm not the actual
teacher but I couldn't know I could
teach it I could teach science I could
teach social science I could teach music
I continues I could teach dance I could
teach history I could teach world
history and American history okay I
could teach English literature Russian
literature and I could teach comparative
literature go ahead yeah between Russian
and English literature
um hey it's time for music here we go
uh-huh
not gonna sing that you know first one
Lord first exercise here we go
well I mean it's not Christian School
it's glory that's from Glory they're
sitting around the campfire the movie
Glory
did you recently watch Glory nope I
always remember because I know I was
gonna use it for a joke wow no I do that
I do like me and Blue Chips but your
version of it I know who chips yeah okay
I got a bunch of jokes about Bluetooth I
just chose not to do them okay well all
right so let's see what's up with the
next one
this is it so sexy yesterday
I was um out with some friends
and after this bar like we were just
walking out and then we just bumped into
another person she was a woman and she
started talking to us and it was great
it was a background
and then suddenly in this group of five
we there was this uh someone fired ah
really bad like the smell was just
[__] terrible okay it was it was
awful okay and
seconds go by and no one mentions it uh
just I'm just I think it's one of those
smells that need to be mentioned yeah
yeah yeah it's so strong that how can
you not how can you ignore that yeah and
I was just in this turmoil in a turmoil
well conflict of should I say something
should I should I shed light on it
should I make a joke about it because
everyone's smelling it
everyone has to be so many years right
but no one's mentioning you
so what would you do in that situation
is it okay in that situation
um no is it okay to mention uh that you
smell something afar or you know a fart
even like the sweat of [__] in a house
okay you know to mention it's obviously
intruding I just get ones like this what
do you think what do you mean ones like
this oh far you're the one who let it
through the way he says fart is just F A
and then a bunch of H's
death
so what you don't get ones like this
what do you mean you don't get ones like
this well I mean I want to let them
through because I want you guys to
understand eviscerate them really
wow playing God playing God
so I mean I would just say here's the
answer
yes it's okay is it okay you know what I
mean you're basically asking expert
you're basically asking somebody is
you're asking us is it okay to mention
you smell something the answer is
resoundingly astoundingly obvious
answers yes the the most dick game show
host of all time
um I think that you uh first of all let
me just say this yes it is is okay a
hundred percent and that's [__]
obvious but how many times have you been
like oh you smell that and someone's
like no no all the time so I wouldn't
assume everyone knows it that's the
first thing I thought actually yeah okay
good so I think this guy is really off
on that yeah he just thinks his nose is
like what what is he like two years old
he hasn't gotten through like I know
realization he might be something from
the other because that is how Calvin
does videos it was so close he zooms out
as just like a baby's body
uh yeah dude that's that's the
everything's all right everything you
might smell even if it's a far dude so
insecure the guy is it okay to tell
people I smell something did it you know
yeah also you know what to say whoever
smells
dealt it I don't believe that but also
dealt it whoever smells like I get it
but what if everyone else in Britain or
wherever he was is just like this should
we uh everyone everyone I don't know
should we should we say something we
don't say something did you get other
videos of the same [__] situation
from other guys
do I say it
smell it doubt it because I know smile
and I don't say something I don't think
it's me
I mean dude you know that's just
absolutely [__] astounding that he
sent that video in but it's okay you
also pull it back just pull it pull it
back pull the hand back it's gonna be
okay why if we see your neck it's okay
yeah yeah if you see where your head is
on it's okay yep you know don't run or
don't smash it in your face all right do
we have another one all right all right
quick one lightning round
hey dangly earring boy hey Chris
QVC there's a guy at my work that
constantly sniffs his nose every five
seconds
and I was thinking about maybe putting
wet cement up his nose okay let me know
what you think I should do
I can't even I know dude it drives me
nuts and and it's almost like
a little while ago the guy wouldn't stop
sniffing dude and I I was losing my mind
I was I was actually looking at him like
because I want him to look at me yeah
I'm right and he never looked at me but
here's the thing if you're willing to be
that confrontational why are you not
willing to ask him
right it's the same thing to me ask him
ask him because you know why because
this way the looking thing is more me
and and I want him to be like you know
why uh it's a trap I want him to be like
why you being a dick like why are you
looking at me like that and then I could
be like oh well it's an anomaly with how
much you're sniffing so you doing that
is putting like the meat out for the
leopard to snatch into there you go trap
it and kill that's what I'm doing okay
so you're trapping leopards it's also
the sexiest way to do it I constantly
think about how to be sexy yeah you
actually are uh so I think if you work
with somebody there's a way to do it
that you're not going to be a you might
be a little bit of a dick no matter what
I mean wet cement you know but there's a
way to do it without being a tremendous
dick which is I've noted I've noticed
you like
or you're always like sniffing is like
they're like something going on like
yeah you're all right not yeah not like
it's something wrong with you but like
yeah is he's a Coke yeah you just do
that no I mean it could be something as
simple as like I have a constant post
nasal drip yeah which was right right
you wouldn't be mad no you wouldn't be
mad anymore no yeah there's a reason
they're okay yeah exactly which is why
you can ask because then they'll be
willing to tell you if there's no reason
yeah then you can just if he's just like
no I don't know what you're talking
about you could be like oh
oh I hate you yeah and that's it what if
he was like why do you keep sniffing he
says because somebody obviously fired
and I don't know if I should admit it
dude I think that
um yeah it's maddening definitely bring
it up or you can say hey man what's the
deal with uh where do you get it and
when he's like what she's like I'll
never mind and then later I'll be like
where do you get it he'll be like what
the coke man like you have a [__]
hard Coke problem like what happened to
me what at the Clipper game
the people that are within us every
episode what the audience
um
and I was at a Clipper game with Dad
Clipper game with Dad going to the
bathroom some guy with like a nice
leather jacket kind of a mock turtleneck
uh beard but like trimmed super
manicured and like short hair that's the
same length as his beard yeah I remember
him like it was yesterday
I see him making the line toward me okay
which is comment of the sporting event
you think people may be walking toward
you but they're not this guy definitely
was walking towards you yeah so by the
time he got to me I was like what kind
of in my body you know wow yeah and he
and so I didn't say that though and all
he said was
do you have any Coke come on and I swear
I I was like I was so shocked first of
all and so I just told him the truth
which was no right and the this is the
reason why it's a story he looked at me
and actually actually said this
really
like I just I am Coke guy what if you
cut to you you had just white powder all
over your face wait where were you where
how old were you uh late teens maybe or
yeah what like 17 18 but probably yeah
not 20 dude I wasn't even 20 yeah you
must have been like
I mean I just saw you I don't know dude
maybe I looked like his like I don't I
have I don't even have a guest dude yeah
yeah yeah maybe you look like somebody
yeah I don't even have a guess that is
pretty but he was stunned that I didn't
have any Coke
uh wow I didn't have any Coke to sell
him he was like shocked
he's just like just so rude to do that
you know what I mean like so rude
all you're doing is saying you look like
a guy who does coke a piece of [__] like
you yeah right that's basically what it
was Unreal okay well that's a funny
story I don't remember that I'm sure you
told me that though yeah no way uh you
haven't all right cool well that's it
well you know you can sign up for a
patreon patreon.com
Lifeline luxury uh you need to get
Christy uh Chrisley tickets that's me
chrissy.com I'll be in Nashville I'll be
in Colorado I'll be in uh Boise Boise
I'm starting to say Boise Boise is right
no it's Boise
um Pennsylvania Montreal all sorts of
places in Canada
uh and if you have a question go to
watch lifeline.com or leave us a message
on the hotline which is what we just did
213-973-8095 if you want if you want and
you should want one-on-one session with
me go to imaginelea.com we'll sort it
all out and uh also uh the lifeline
merch is at lifelinemerch.com uh we
appreciate it how about you leave a uh
uh what do you call it comment and uh
make sure you're subscribed that helps
us out we appreciate you guys thank you
very much
hello
please hello hello